hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcasts the opioid crisis and
other novel psychoactive substances
forensic toxicological perspectives
presented by robert Middleburg he is the
laboratory director and senior vice
president of laboratory operations in
quality assurance at adam s I am
Marjorie torres of labyrinth and I'll be
your moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by laberd's
laberd's is leading scientific social
networking websites and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
any time you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located in the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen well answer as many of your
questions as you have time for at the
end of the presentation also please
notice that you'll be viewing the
presentation in the slide window - and
watched over note just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of the
presentation window are you the security
button to let us know that you're having
a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
button in the bottom left corner and
follow the process to obtain your credit
please join me in welcoming dr. Robert
Melbourne I will now turn the
presentation over to him hello everyone
as Margie said I'm dr. Rob Middleburg
from an MS labs and Willow Grove
Pennsylvania and this pleasure to be
here with you today I'm going to be
speaking to a little bit different
perspective of the opioid crisis that we
hear about almost every day in the news
for which some legislation was just
passed but I'm also going to include
what's also known as novel psychoactive
substances of which a lot of the new
opioids are part of that group and I'll
be talking about forensic toxicological
perspectives which is a little bit
different than what you hear about on
the news it's the laboratories challenge
when trying to keep up with what's going
on out in the universe not only in the
United States but what we see going on
around the world I do have to alert you
that I am a forensic toxicologist by
trade and as such it's hard to get a lot
of the points across I'm going to be
making without having some disturbing
photographs in the presentation as they
come up if you want to turn your head if
you do not like photographs like that
please do and as I switch slides you'll
be able to turn back with that we may as
well jump right into the presentation
there are a few learning objectives here
one of them is to talk about
toxicological perspectives of
perspectives of the opioid crisis as
well as that of novel psychoactive
substances next we'll be talking about
some of the challenges that we face as
bioanalytical toxicology laboratories
and trying to keep up with this rapidly
changing area of concern and lastly
we'll be talking about one particular
instrumental technique that we use to a
fairly weld and that's mass spectrometry
and the role it plays in trying to help
with these problems so hardly a day goes
by that you can't turn on the news or
read a newspaper or go on the internet
and find a picture like this where
somebody is laying on the ground who has
overdosed on some substance it's hard to
know without doing some testing what it
is but here's a medic are hopefully
trying to help this individual this is
one of the more disturbing pictures that
I've seen come across my desk and that
is a picture of a grandmother and a and
another fella who has been sort of I
guess you could say wiped out by heroin
at least learning this picture but the
more disturbing part is in the backseat
you will find a child the grand child of
this woman sitting there right away
watching as this
very very sad but pretty much
commonplace and lastly of course there's
not a day that goes by that an
individual isn't affected by this
whether it be through the death of a son
a daughter a mother a father a
grandparent friends family members that
the opioid crisis and the novel
psychoactive crisis doesn't affect in
fact it's estimated at least this coming
year will be between 65,000 and 70,000
people who die from this about 170 per
day that is a significant issue
certainly is greater than a lot of other
common causes of death including that
from driving while impaired so to get
everybody on the same page I thought I'd
just refresh for those of you who need a
refreshing or for those who don't know
exactly what the job of a forensic
toxicologist is or a forensic toxicology
lab that's simply to look at fluids and
tissues and other biological matter to
try to see if we can determine what may
have been implicated in an individual's
death or maybe why they're impaired such
as Walter driving so we have both an
analytical perspective to what we do as
well as an interpretive perspective they
have to recompute our analyses we're
often asked what does the presence of
that substance mean so where were we
it wasn't that long ago I've been doing
this kind of work for a little bit more
than 30 years now so in the good old
days we would be looking for therapeutic
agents an environmental agents pesticide
some metals people still will try to
poison each other with the Stallions and
the arsenic there are hard for us to
detect we had our simple drugs of abuse
of course ethanol drinking alcohol and
stimulants methamphetamine maybe ecstasy
and more recent
years we had our traditional opioids
that the heroin and the oxycontin
oxycodone cannabinoids marijuana and
benzodiazepines the tranquilizers they
ate in the days of Pam family of
medicines and we had a few others such
as LSD and PCP and a few other things
that we'd be confronted with and those
were the good old days and I like to say
at that point life was good because it
wasn't all that difficult to keep up but
today we've reached the point where it's
good life good death good grief and it's
become a real problem for us and we'll
start with some basic information about
novel psychoactive substances or NPs
compounds and their form of collage
eclis they're active what we call
analogues of substances that are already
out there they're meant to mimic their
pharmacological actions a lot of these
were developed by drug companies long
ago and I'll talk about that a little
bit later but they were never brought to
the industry because of some problems
associated with them and a lot of these
are coming from other countries the
classes of compounds on a broad scale
that we talked about here again are
cannabinoids stimulants opioids
benzodiazepines dissociative agent and
whose sin again I'll cover those each
one of those in a little bit of detail
again many of these were developed long
ago in the 70s in the 80s and shelved by
pharmaceutical companies and I think
what probably happens today is a lot of
people who want to synthesize these
compounds go and they just do some
patent rolling and see what's out there
and what was shelved and what's
available and that's a good starting
place for them so why should we care
about these things well as one of the
great 20th century philosophers has said
this is a big-league problem so why are
they made why do people want to use
these things why are they out there well
one of the reasons and I'll talk about
this in a little bit more
is to get the better high people who
like to abuse substances are always
looking for a better hi and that's one
of the drivers and also one of the
reasons for making these is to escape
existing drug laws the drug laws which
I'll talk about in just a slide or two
or written in such ways that oftentimes
they're vague and makes it very
difficult for a substance to be
controlled even though it might look
like something else analytically I'll
spend more time of this on this at the
end of the presentation we have some
significant challenges and one of the
ones I have here is keeping up with the
Joneses and that takes two forms
actually one of them is trying to keep
up with all the new substances that keep
coming to market that we see out on the
street that in and of itself is
difficult and also is trying to keep up
analytically with what other
laboratories are trying to do and trying
to stay ahead so it's keeping up with
the Joneses on a couple of fronts the
technologies that we are generally using
today and I'll talk again in detail
about them later GCMs gas chromatography
mass spectrometry liquid chromatography
tandem mass spectrometry and we also
talk about liquid chromatography and
time-of-flight mass spectrometry these
techniques are very expensive they
require a lot of resources oftentimes
you have to have staff who know how to
use these and what to do with them they
they're not that simple of techniques to
use especially when you're talking about
LC ms/ms n LC Tom as I say is a tested
test and that's a really hard question
to answer our laboratory has been
keeping up with this challenge of the
novel psychoactive substances almost
from its outset so a lot of government
agencies come to us for data because we
have it we do a lot of the testing
around the country and some outside of
the country and the tests we do we try
to keep up to date by turning the test
over every
three to six months whether it be blood
or urine or other lot of biologicals and
that's quite a task we have part of our
Rd group that just spends their time
trying to keep up with these compounds
and you'll see the gravity of this issue
very shortly and other laboratories are
still doing tests they say they test for
novel psychoactive substances of
compounds that we haven't seen for five
or six or seven or eight years now so a
test is not a test and I urge and
implore anyone who's seeking this kind
of work if you want to avoid a whole
bunch of false negatives to seek a
laboratory that is doing a comprehensive
test for these compounds I say to what
end why do we want to do this well
because it's a public health and a
public safety concern for us as I showed
you in some of the earlier photos so how
does a laboratory try to stay relevant
well these are all the ways that we use
and you will see we're lucky in that we
have a crime laboratory we serve as a
crime laboratory for a lot of viewers
local jurisdictions so we can see what
they're seeing and then try to relate
that to what we're going to see in
biologicals we also have casework in
which we are constantly looking for new
things that may be in somebody's blood
or urine we have government data that we
look at their databases and literature
and conferences and so forth and so on
so there's about ten or twelve different
things that we have to integrate just in
trying to keep up with what's going out
going on in the world so let's just jump
right into the different kinds of
compounds that are out there first we'll
start with designer opioids and
unfortunately it often takes the death
of an individual like this this is
Prince of course the musician we died I
guess at this point a year or two ago
and that's the kind of thing that
unfortunately brings these kinds of
problems to the forefront again every
day about a hundred and seventy people
are succumbing to this and most of us
aren't familiar with those individual
except if they've touched our lives
personally but when somebody like this
dies then it becomes a bigger issue for
us nationally so we will look at opioids
novel psychoactive opioids or designer
earthly opioids they are meant to act at
the same receptors as traditional
opioids the MU Kappa Delta receptors
mainly and you will see they have a wide
variety of structures over here we have
our classic morphing structure and
that's how a lot of opioids that you see
or that you will receive
pharmaceutically or design the
oxycodones and the hydrocodones
they all mimic morphine to some in some
respect in terms of structure the
problem for us is that these newer
compounds that are coming out on the
market aah 7921 and fentanyl which is
both a pharmaceutical compound and
you'll see an illicit compound you four
seven seven zero zero which has a lot of
prevalence today these are compounds
that are structurally unrelated to
morphine yet manage to interact at the
receptors to elicit similar effects and
that's the beauty of receptors in their
design and that their ability to
interact with several kinds of compounds
and still induce similar effect so to
show you the kind of timeline we've seen
starting back in about March of 2013 we
saw this compound a H 7921 come the
market and shortly thereafter we started
seeing fentanyl and fentanyl derivatives
we've always seen fentanyl because
fentanyl is used again pharmacologically
or pharmaceutical e to help treat
people's pain but we start seeing lots
more of it on the street seemingly from
illicit sources and then some
derivatives started showing up or analog
Masekela fentanyl then as you keep going
through the list you'll see more and
more compounds and finally one of the
real problems we are seeing
today is a compound that we first saw
about August of 2016 as did the rest of
the country called car fentanyl and
we'll talk a little bit about that as we
go on so what happened here
to make these such a problem over the
last five to ten years well we had two
common users and as I mentioned earlier
they're always seeking it better high or
cheaper high if they can find it and
that's one of the major drivers of drugs
of abuse that appear on the street but
what really happened was pain management
wasn't that long ago maybe ten years ago
or so that it was believed that people
were being under treated for pain and in
fact it used to be believed not to all
that long though that actually children
didn't really feel pain the way adults
do but we now know that's just not true
there's no reason to believe a child
wouldn't feel pain like an adult
nevertheless when you couple all that
together
there was this wide swing of the
pendulum towards treating people for
pain and part of that became the ready
prescription of opioids to individuals
that became a real issue and what you
might hear about on the news today our
pharmaceutical companies being
investigated criminally for their role
in the opioid crisis and that they
promoted use of the various compounds
that physicians would readily prescribe
now physicians have also gotten in
trouble for for the handing out like
candy as one puts it of these opioid
type compounds so what has that created
that has created a whole bunch of people
who have become addicted to these
compounds and as the pendulum has
started to swing back towards the center
where there's some control over this
unfortunately we have these individuals
who can no longer get prescriptions
because they've become abused so they
turn to the street in the black-market
to get these opioid substances kinds of
effects people are seeking of course are
the high the euphoria that one gets from
these pain medications of course pain
relief is at the heart of it how a lot
of people get started on them and then
unfortunately what happens with them
when you start talking toxicological E
is you develop a central nervous system
depression respiratory depression you go
into a coma and then one died when you
look at these esoteric opioids that
we're seeing you can see over time
remember this then when you look at this
x-axis here we're only looking at 2016
and part of 2017 so it's starting in
January of 2016 we saw a lot of this
asset ile fentanyl but now what we're
starting to see is a compound for a npp
which is both a starting material for
the synthesis of fentanyl but also a
metabolite of fentanyl in that respect
it's also known as DES propia Neil
fentanyl you'll see all these other
compounds that are coming up and you'll
see car fentanyl on the rise as well as
a number of others so our positivity for
these select esoteric opioids just from
January of 2016 through August of 2017
you will see effects no we've seen
almost 15,000 cases involving Sentinel
and you'll see all these other compounds
and how many of those seen these numbers
have obviously changed through today and
some of these you'll find in the same
individual it's not unusual to find
fentanyl and heroin six ma'am is a
metabolite of heroin so it's not unusual
to see the two of those together and
you'll see a number of these other
things also grouped together in a single
individual when you look at fentanyl
analogues that are putting been
described by you of the UNODC you will
see a list of compounds that are even
more extensive than the ones we've been
seeing the United States happens to have
seem to have a bigger crisis right now
with Oakley
the rest of the world but it is in the
rest of the world as well and in fact
often times they will see things in
Europe and other countries before they
make their way to the United States for
us things we are starting to see through
September of this year some of these
newer compounds they're all derivatives
of fentanyl and it's hard to imagine
that people could create this many types
of compounds and they're still doing it
I often say that the people who create
these if they could put their chemistry
skills to good use who knows what kind
of diseases we might have either a cure
for or at least some control so there's
been some attempts at legislation
through the years as these compounds
started to come to market not only the
opioids but other novel psychoactive
micro active substances but it's a real
challenge trying to keep up so here's a
piece of recent legislation introduced
by Senator Ron Johnson of Wisconsin in
2017 and this is a a bill trying to
control substances substances based on
their core chemical structure but that's
still an issue for us because we have
this word the way things are controlled
it usually names a compound and it says
analogues and questions are always
brought up what does an analogue mean
from a chemistry perspective and there
have been cases I have dismissed been
dismissed out of court somebody who's
selling these substances because no one
could agree on what an analogue is this
bill is trying to get around that and
whether we ever get there or not is a
whole different question hopefully we
will because it's hard to keep up by
controlling them on a one-on-one basis
but if you look at Google not just our
data but you look at Google and you look
at trends here you will see the various
compounds listed on the bottom here and
their prevalence as they are started to
be seen from only about a two-year
period of time
as time has progressed and you start
looking at other compounds things that
we didn't even know would be out there
the major player that we're starting to
see of course is car fentanyl and it has
just taken off over the last year year
and a half of time it started off in the
Midwest mainly in Ohio that's where it
was first seen especially in the
Cincinnati area there are a number of
hypotheses as to why that was but it is
certainly now all throughout the eastern
United States New England states are
having an awful problem with it as is
Pennsylvania and a few other states and
that's just the not only car fentanyl
but the other designer opioids as well
it has made its way to about middle of
the United States not so much of it on
the west coast and if you don't know
drugs of abuse tend to be geographical
and they will make their way there they
are there just not to the same degree
right now so I kind of put this slide in
here because it's somewhat I guess one
could say uemura's but not really
showing how we've had to change things
as time goes on just from April the end
of April of 2016 and then the end of May
of 2016 the end of March of 2017 how
many cases we've seen of these
individual compounds and how the numbers
have jumped dramatically or with just
that short period of time so when we
look at the compounds we're seeing we
see a lot of again fentanyl derivatives
a compound that came on the market
probably about six months or so ago is a
Creole fentanyl I mentioned for a npp to
you before this compound itself is
controlled so that people can no longer
get it in theory easily by ordering it
on the internet because people can
synthesize fentanyl in their kitchen
it's not that difficult once you get the
Internet all
the recipe off the internet when you
look at the differences of these
compounds oftentimes you will see a lot
of the differences appearing somewhere
around where the propanone group is they
make changes there sometimes it has a
whole different part of the molecule
that's affected so this is a real
problem people seemingly just
synthesizing anything they can throwing
them out on the street not a whole lot
of quality control a lot of quality
assurance going on certainly very little
pharmacological testing and the
interesting thing about this is that
people are willing to try these things
and actually when they hear about people
dying from these things that's actually
a good sign for the abusers at this
point because it tells them the stuff
must be very good now if only they can
figure out how to titrate it so that
they don't die like would be great so a
few sacrifice sacrifice your lambs is
actually good for the drug trade and
here's car fentanyl down here talk a
little bit more about that and these are
the kinds of concentrations we see they
range from the sub mana gram per
milliliter or some parts per billion all
the way up depending on the compound
sometimes the microgram per mil range so
a laboratory that's doing this kind of
testing has to have very very sensitive
technique ones that can handle very low
concentrations and also ones that can
handle some high concentration it's a
real challenge for the analytical
laboratory so to talk a little bit about
Clarke fentanyl this was first
synthesized in 1974 it was available not
for human use but for putting down large
animals such as elephants and lions and
hippos and other animals like that to
trample eyes them so you could tell
there's probably a pretty powerful drug
about 10,000 times more potent than
morphine about a hundred times more
potent than fentanyl that is really
dangerous material I'll talk about this
on the neck
slide and I will warn you the next
couple slides there are pictures of that
one might consider sensitive but it was
linked to the 2002 neuroses and Moscow
movie that was that resulted in the the
deaths of about 150 out of 850 people it
was a had nificant emergence as a street
drug approximately mid 2016 and its
metabolite is car fentanyl so here are
some pictures from inside the theater
here this was a series of Chechen rebels
who went into a Moscow theater where
there was a concert being put on by a
group called Nordhoff and they held all
the people in there hostage the ones in
black are the hostage takers and this
went on for several days and ever on
about the fourth day the the government
of russia had enough of this and they
send in their federal troops or tried to
and that wasn't going to work real well
so what they decided to do is pipe
something through the HVAC system the
air conditioning system a chemical and
they did that and what happened was all
the hostage takers died about 40 of them
did about another 100 or so of the
patrons a number of people managed to
get out some were hospitalized for sure
and the closer analyzed and what was
found was car fentanyl and another
compound remi fentanyl rather that was a
wise decision to pipe that through a
HVAC system one could wonder but they
did and
airborne concentrations were very
significant and resulted of course in
the deaths so when you look at car
fentanyl you'll see its structure only
changes from fentanyl through a
carboxylate group being added and what
you'll then get is a dental D alkylation
in terms of more fentanyl as the
metabolite you four seven seven zero
zero is another compound was still
seeing a fair amount of it was developed
by the Upjohn pharmaceutical company in
the 1970s and it was derived from one of
the first compounds we saw out on the
market aah 7921 design doesn't selected
Kappa ligand but also interacts a new
receptors and others as well to elicit
the effects it supposedly you might have
heard on the news about this compound
w18 that was seen up in canada and we
saw a couple cases down in florida it's
ten thousand two is ten thousand times
more powerful than morphine there's some
debate whether it really is an opioid
some discreet studies have demonstrated
that it doesn't act at opioid receptors
but what I would tell you it's not just
w18 or some other new derivatives now
that may be equally or more potent than
this but what I would tell you is that
if the people on the street are telling
you it makes them feel like they're on
an opioid then they probably are it
doesn't really matter pharmacologically
because street pharmacology often rules
the day so people believe this is going
to give them an effect like an opioid
they're going to abuse it for that
reason certainly I could spend a lot of
time talking about all the other opioids
that are out there and we're seeing but
I think for purposes of time and sports
exploring some of the other novel
psychoactive substances including the
synthetic cannabinoids this is a problem
this is from a hospital actually local
to us where fake weed overdoses
overwhelmed
Valley hospital's this is a doctor who
was interviewed about what they're
seeing psychotic patients young people
coming in with rapid heartbeats and all
kinds of adverse effects and we'll talk
about them here's another case I'm
looking fellow if you read the headline
here man high on synthetic marijuana
decapitated wife killed dog cut off his
own eye and hand while he was high on
these synthetic cannabinoids a neighbor
heard the ruckus knocked on the door and
this is what he was greeted by so these
are pretty serious compounds as well
interesting compounds they were first
synthesized or the beginnings of them in
1960 they were developed as analogs of
THC the active ingredient in marijuana
the first one hu - 10 a lot of them had
these names based on where they were
made first at Hebrew University and
probably compound number 210 in a series
they were making the 1970s Pfizer
discovered the CP series of compounds
and coincidentally in 1988 in 1990 the
cannabinoid receptors right down to 5 TB
1 and C B to C B 1 main found mainly in
the brain that's a receptor that people
are trying to have these compounds
interact with CB 2 UV 2 receptors found
mainly in the periphery involved with
some autoimmune type responses in the
1990s John Hoffman at Clemson University
synthesized a series of compounds and
some people may have heard of called the
J WH series named after John W Huffman
we really don't see these anymore
they're gone
they came the other day and they're gone
pretty much and from 2000 on we've seen
a series of other compounds so these
compounds first appeared in Europe
approximately 2004 at of all places the
psyckadeli came to the United States
somewhere around 2008 and we believe
they're being synthesized mainly in
emerging economies such as China and in
fact we know a lot of them
most of them do come from China some
synthesised in Mexico in a few other
places as well they're originally
believed to be a blend of herbal
products and the fact were being sold as
potpourri type products there's a saying
on that on the packages not for human
consumption but of course they were
meant for human consumption and like
almost all novel psychoactive substances
these are here to stay you're not fads
we've gone past that point where we
consider these compounds to be fads and
we have moved on to believe that this is
just something we're going to have to
deal with from this point forward
instead of cannabinoids they're
structures all have similarities they
have a core ring structure generally
attached to another ring and then
there's a tail of some sort and this is
a nice wheel that demonstrates the kinds
of things that represent each one of
these components of the molecule so
here's a picture of Delta 9 THC the
active ingredient in marijuana one of
the interesting things about it is if
you look at it from a pharmacological
perspective it's one of the few
compounds you'll see that doesn't have a
nitrogen in it but when you start
looking at the vastness of the types of
synthetic cannabinoids that we've seen
early on up here
I'm sorry early on we were seeing these
kinds of compounds and they've made
their way down subsequently but if you
look at the structures of those
compounds you will see they have
absolutely no semblance to that of Delta
9 THC yet interact with the cannabinoid
receptor cb1 receptors anyhow this is
what the ones on the bottom are the ones
that we typically are seeing today so to
put it in perspective for you in terms
of a challenge for an analytical
laboratory if you look at 2010 here's
that jwh series of compounds this is
what we were seeing as you move forward
through the years you'll see in 2014 all
of a sudden the list got somewhat
different and longer and you don't even
see any of the jwh compounds and now
when you look at 2016
this is where things reside today these
compounds appear to change
I used to say monthly but it's not
monthly I don't even think it's weekly
anymore it might be on a daily basis
that is a real challenge for an
analytical laboratory
first of all these compounds are very
hard to detect anyhow the president low
concentrations and now they they keep
changing very very challenging it's just
to show you that in the brain of course
various areas of the brain do various
different things for us and we have
these cb1 receptors and all of them so
you get a multitude of effect and here
is this lays those effect out from the
central nervous system perspective a lot
of agitation and and psychosis is noted
especially when people show up in
emergency rooms that are often
hallucinating and they're delirious it
causes a lot of problems that way from a
cardiovascular perspective and we'll go
through this in just a slide or two you
will see everything from tachycardia to
myocardial infarction and then you see
other organ systems are affected in
other ways there are some driving cases
colleague of mine Barry Logan and some
others looked at a series of cases early
on so people are abusing these
substances and driving is something else
for us to be concerned with and here's
an unfortunate case that was reported in
the Journal of Forensic Sciences of a 23
year old who abused a compound called AM
2201 was with his family went home
family didn't hear from him and what he
did was he started self-mutilating
himself with the final wound being a
slash to the neck no source of foul play
and this is typical of what you will see
with these compounds not in them as much
as they cause death themselves although
that is happening today but oftentimes
people do things under the influence of
them that result in death and injury
interesting here in 2012 there are three
cases of acute kidney injury
the use of this compound XLR 11 and that
was seen in Wyoming and then five other
states and then then in Alabama the good
news is here while some people needed
hemodialysis none of them died this is
what is fairly serious and something
people should understand here's a series
of three teenagers 13 16 and 16 who
smoked when these synthetic cannabinoid
products suffered myocardial infarction
you don't expect an mi to occur in
teenagers and that tells you some of
there's very serious adverse effects of
these compounds and now we know that
these compounds are being used or by
medical examiner's forensic pathologist
as sole causes of death no one that I'm
aware of has ever been recorded to have
died from the use of marijuana there was
one case a whole bunch of years ago that
kind of suspect but no one really dies
from marijuana but people do die from
this compound as a direct cause of these
compounds as direct causes of death
moving into stimulant it used to be
called bath salts we call them designer
stimulants they do cause the death of
individuals pretty readily
they act as stimulants much like method
in the methamphetamine family of
compounds effects include agitation
kepada other than this a lot of
psychosis this is interesting thirst and
bruxism people who go to rave parties
who abuse these kinds of substances at
rave parties they sell water for $10 a
bottle ourselves because people must
drink they also sell these ring pops so
people don't grind their teeth which is
what bruxism in so these have three main
effects that people are seeking one is a
stimulant effect and that's mediated by
the neuro
epinephrine and pathogenic effects by
dopamine the hallucinogenic effects by
Sierra tonin these are the kinds of
compounds we see mainly the designer
ones are derivatives of cathinone and
you'll see such terms as ecstasy which
has been out on the market for some time
but these are some of the newer
compounds that we'll see out there today
so you can see the different
neurotransmitters and the kinds of
things they do and these are the reasons
why people are abusing them these
compounds either activate the receptors
directly they stimulate release of these
various in order transmitters or they
will block the reuptake so they can stay
in the synaptic cleft and keep hitting
receptors in terms of hallucinogens
designer hallucinogens we see the N Mo's
in methoxy benzyl groups and the voxi
benzyl groups it's the other part of the
molecule that changes this part of the
molecule changes while the enmity oxy
benzyl part stays the same and they
receptors they could be full agonist
partial agonist so forth and so on other
whose citizens that are different method
said amine 3 methoxy PCP and cyclo Dean
they all work at the MDR receptors and
methodius part 8 receptor their
antagonist and other compounds you may
have heard of that react that way
ketamine and PCP and these actually
changed the organic nature of the brain
causing such things as only lesions
which are vacuoles you'll find in the
brain that don't belong there these are
the structures of a Huson engines varied
structures a lot of them have some
similarities to PCP however general
effects certainly agitation combative
behaviors
almost
noted they do cause seizures and
ultimately they can cause death as well
so when we look at they the stimulants
on the left and who was citizens on the
right these are some of the compounds
we've been seeing in the last group are
the novel benzodiazepines I stay here
tongue-in-cheek it is a lamp I raise a
lamb at tizzle and mary had a little
lamb
it just goes on and on these are the
kinds of compounds we've been seeing
that I've been seeing around the world
in terms of technology what we know is
that trying to keep up as I've mentioned
many times already is a real challenge
and you have to have techniques that are
flexible and able to keep up with what's
going on so some of the requirements of
this new technology it has to have high
throughput because there are a lot of
cases to be looked at they have to be
discriminating you'll see as you may
have noticed they're very small changes
to these molecules so you have to be
able to differentiate one compound from
the next you have to be able to catch
new things I call them out of scope
findings things that just appear that
they're not part of your list of things
that you normally look for so you have
to have some pretty good chemists
available you can see these I'll call
them unidentified flying Peaks that you
can actually put the structure together
and figure out what they are and you
have to have conformation techniques the
hallmark of a good forensic test is one
that has both a screen component on a
conformation test and hopefully by two
different analytical techniques but
sometimes we're confronted with having
to use the same technique twice and our
specimens aren't necessarily the best
some people die and it's weeks before
they're found and again the next slide
is a picture that you may want to turn
your head for but it's not unusual to
get specimens from a body that looks
like this very different than a hospital
specimen that's a nice neat serum or
urine sample samples from a body like
this are very very difficult
deal with some other non technology
related issues is where do we get
standards for these compounds and who's
making them analytically you're supposed
to have a compound that you compare what
you find in a person to but if were the
ones or other laboratories are the ones
finding the compound for the first time
there is no substance available to
compare it to so no reference materials
and some companies are trying to keep up
but that's a challenge for them also in
terms of what we find in humans where
you have to look for metabolites and for
the first time in our company's history
we've had to do animal studies
microsomal studies we've had to do
synthesis of various metabolites that we
think based on pharmacology and
toxicology might be present sometimes
you're right sometimes we're wrong and
then you have to have good techniques to
identify all part of the challenges and
should we be looking for these things
from a qualitative nature not only what
are they but from a quantitative nature
how much is there does it really matter
how much there is there's some debate in
the world of forensic toxicology whether
that really matters so and just keeping
up because of all of these things and
all the other pieces that I've been
talking about throughout this
presentation makes it difficult for us
the technology in terms of mass
spectrometry we used to use gas
chromatography mass spectrometry that's
kind of gone by the wayside for a number
of reasons today for these types of
substances we're now using techniques
such as lcms LSD Tov LC q Toph they're
all forms of mass spectrometry all
giving you different kinds of
information the top type methods are
called high resolution they give you
exact mass so it gives you a really good
idea but if you found something what it
is but still there are challenges there
there's no panacea for any of this so we
apply whatever tools we can when
we can to the situation we do hope there
are some future things that are going to
make our lives a little easier in terms
of mass spectrometry such as rapid fire
and I have no build in whatever else
instrument manufactures are constantly
coming to market with we try to use
those tools you should understand a lot
of these tools the instruments started
about a half a million dollars apiece
and sometimes can go up from there so
it's not an easy challenge not only
analytically but from a fiscal
perspective for laboratories to keep up
they'll tell you the gravity of the
problem the College of American
Pathologists has come out with a
proficiency test for these novel
psychoactive substances and they keeps
growing in terms of what's in it all
analytical laboratories who do this kind
of work have to be proficiency tested in
other words externally challenged to
make sure that you are actually doing
the job you say you are able to do so
the conclusions here or that novel
psychoactive substances are here to stay
they're not going anywhere it's not a
fad we used to think it was a fad but
not anymore and the landscape hopefully
you've absorbed from this presentation
changes sometimes on a daily basis again
something that's very Chow to the
analytical laboratory all these
substances are dangerous up to and
potential to include death and labs who
are going to get into this game really
have to be able to keep up they can't
say they do a few tests that were
prevalent ten years ago and say they're
doing a good job because they're not
doing is helping to eradicate both the
public health and public safety concerns
that we all confront each and every day
I do have a couple acknowledgments a
couple colleagues of mine here dr. Barry
Logan and dr. Shari Cinco both of who of
the forefront of the research and the
work that's being done with these kinds
of compounds and
these are key players in terms of novel
psychoactive substance technology and
research with that that's the end of the
formal presentation and I hope this was
informative to you and I'd like to turn
it over for questions
thank you dr. Middleburg for that
informative presentation we will not
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window type
your questions into the box that appears
on your screen and click on the send
button
well answer is money if your questions
the three Oh time for let's get started
our first question is why do you think
MPs are here to stay and not bad well
it's been now about ten years since they
made their way onto the US market and
with other substances that have been
fads through the years through my career
they have maybe a one or two year window
these compounds again are still here
after about ten years and while they
keep changing the pharmacological
classes of them stay the same and
unfortunately it's affected almost all
classes as you've seen in the
presentation of drugs of abuse from
stimulants to opioids the
benzodiazepines to hallucinogens and so
forth and so on
the demand is high companies around the
world keep making them or people around
the world keep making them and it leads
us to believe for those reasons that
these compounds aren't going anywhere
thank you our next question is what do
you think is the answer to stemming
debuts of NPs I think there there's a
dual front to that first of course is
working with countries like China and
other countries to help stem the flow in
terms of the synthesis of these
substances and there have been some
successes there recently in that respect
and working with China and other places
it's hard because they're large
revenue generators to give you an idea a
kilo of heroin on the march on the
street will generate maybe a couple
hundred thousand dollars whereas a kilo
of fentanyl on the street might pull in
about two and a half million dollars so
drug dealers go where the money is and
that's a reason for them to be produced
but stemming the flow their works to a
small degree I think the real issue
though however is stemming demand we
often spend a lot of resources on the
law enforcement side but perhaps not as
much on the individuals who are abusing
these substances and helping them not
want to go down that road because it is
a really really hard road once one
starts to go down thank you our last
question is for a laptop wants to start
analyzing for MPS what advice do you
have for them do you think there will
ever be a sufficient pset4 NTS well
there's two questions there the first
one which let's address the the first
one the second one first point of care
device is point of care testing it's
where a lot of the world is going both
not only for medical testing but
hopefully for other forms of testing
perhaps in the world of forensic
toxicology as well as there are a number
of those tests out there a lot of them
though are just screening tests are not
compliment I'll give you an idea what
might be present but not exactly what it
is the problem with the point of care
testing is that these compounds as
you've seen change so frequently that
it's hard to imagine that a
point-of-care device could actually
produce to keep up with that pace so I
don't think they'll ever be
point-of-care testing that will really
help with these challenges the first
question is if you're not in this game
already don't jump in now that's my
advice it's just too difficult
our laboratory again has been at this
now for about 10 or so years and we've
been again turning over the tests every
three to six months to jump in at this
stage
was going to take an inordinate amount
of resources a lot of skills a lot of
investment both in capital material as
well as human skill sets and just a very
very significant challenge or a number
of labs that are trying to keep up like
ours they're really the labs at this
stage that I think can do the best job
moving forward because they're just
building on what their knowledge base
already is I would like to once again
thank dr. Robert metal Burke for his
presentation I would also like to claim
glabrous for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I wanna
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
to February of 2018 you'll receive an
email from labret letting you know in
this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcements
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon goodbye